what's going on reject nation Greg Alva
here the Kyler men here the collar man
from the fan Theory YouTube channel do
yourself a favor check out the fan
Theory YouTube channel fan Theory
YouTube channel anyway we're gonna watch
you know like people wanted us to check
out some Ryan Gosling sketches from SNL
it is my favorite SNL sketch of all time
is the digital short Santa baby never
did a reaction to it but I watched it
plenty of times so when I heard his
return to SNL I was excited and I don't
have television like I have a television
what's it called I don't have cable at
the box I live you just watch Channel
four I think most people actually are
that way yeah yeah yeah so I only wait
to see what they put up on YouTube
because what they put up on YouTube is
presumably a good sketch this one it was
sent to us papyrus one of the Ryan
Gosling sketches so excited he's
returning Ryan Gosling's one of my
all-time favorite actors I just love him
and patron today shoutout was gonna be
for Erica Tuesday because I'm sure Erica
Tuesday if she had a chance to make love
with the Gossman
I'm sure she would as would odd wouldn't
we all wouldn't we all
it happened again
I thought was behind me mo the dreams
came back I was up all night I can't
hear I can't sleep
what's wrong
you know it's me
[Music]
again I forgot about it for years but
then I remember them avatar the giant
International blockbuster used the
papyrus yeah he just highlighted avatar
he clicked the drop-down menu and then
he just randomly selected papyrus like a
child I know you're worried about the
sequels that are coming out they're
making more I think I heard that do
change the you show me this before
I don't even think this is literally
papyrus maybe that was a starting point
they clearly my to find this but
whatever they did
and now here I am doing what I vow to
[Laughter]
see him do as little things live
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you remember the our logo yeah it was
tribal futuristic funny wrist
[Music]
that's Comic Sans
[Music]
it's so random but it's so like I'm
surprised that this wasn't done sooner
but it's so it's sad because like avatar
is the number one movie of all time
and it did huge such a funny what-if
sketch it's obviously just some writer
in the S&L room it was like you know
what I noticed this is the papyrus Ryan
Gosling is so good at comedy he doesn't
do enough comedy I feel cuz he's a great
dramatic actor and that's a big reason
why his comedy is so funny have you seen
the santa baby sketch uh yes yeah yeah
and that's another one where he's just
so committed to the drama of it and he
has that deadpan like he doesn't even
seem close to resembling that he
realizes - how humorous the situation
it's he hits all the right beats and
yeah this is story of like obsession and
such an amazing actor yeah such an
amazing act man every shot of that was
so beautifully done yeah it was so
believable like it is really upset about
this I love the back story that they
give him with the characters who are
just like you've shown this to me
Shakira you're upset about the sequels
there may be more god I just love his
deadpan humor he's so frickin hysterical
at this stuff man I want to watch more
of his sketch it makes you uncomfortable
cuz you're like wait he's serious
exactly and I never noticed that the
papyrus font oh really I've never
noticed do you notice that well graphic
designer graphic design sometimes so
yeah like it was a really big deal when
it first came out everyone in my
creative studio they're just like this
is blasphemous like I really it was kind
of an embarrassment and we're like James
Cameron was like yeah yeah and I like
these like digital shorts that are
spoofs like genre spoofs you know
because this is
like I'm set psychological obsession
thrillers I've noticed like the four out
with their sketches it tends to be like
there's the character one or two who who
are really like obsessed with something
and there's always like other characters
surrounding them who are like pointing
out like this is really a big deal
brilliantly done oh man I can't wait to
watch more of Ryan Gosling sketches here
yeah
Eric a Tuesday she's a beautiful girl
with a beautiful soul I met her a few
times actually I've heard you talk about
her yeah you better she was at the party
he's obsessed with her she's the only
patron who I've said you should come
he's a good friend of John's actually
close friend of John she's actually a
graphic designer
- she's an artist as well the papyrus
font probably upset her - actually yeah
I'm sure it did upset her and Erica look
I don't really know much about your
romantic or sexual life but I'm hoping
that along the way you get to have a
sexual encounter with Ryan Gosling where
VR goggles recorded so that I could live
vicariously through you I could get
those VR glasses and then know what you
experienced with the Goss wing that's
what he calls it is that we go swing
wing that's the best I could do my gosh
thing dusting in custody
knowing name the Ryan Gosling a ding but
Erica thanks for being a part of our
pastry on me comfortable
keep drying stay pretty because that
will get you far in life for the next 10
years it's true and you'll be a
wonderful cougar one of these days I
like to show my appreciation to the
patrons your battery's almost dead your
battery's almost dead oh it's not a
metaphor it's a real thing yeah
subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bow follow the
collar men on Instagram and Twitter
check out my youtube channel that's the
main thing you're here for check out his
youtube channel fan Theory good day Mike
you
[Music]